(tense staccato music)
- I was having a lot of
fatigue and body aches.
I just thought it was
exhaustion from traveling.
But the next morning
I woke up with rashes all over my hands.
The lesions started spreading
to the more usual suspect areas,
so that really made the
doctors sort of confirm
that what I had was monkeypox.
- [Narrator] Kevin Kwong
believes he was first infected
in late June, about a
month after monkeypox cases
began to be reported in the U.S.
- It was sort of this,
like, mystery disease.
I think I approached things cautiously,
but at the same time,
I wasn't even sure what to be aware of.
- [Narrator] By late July,
the World Health Organization
declared it a global health emergency,
their highest level of alert.
- It will not be the
next COVID-19 pandemic,
but as a public health professional,
I am very worried about what's unfolding,
because this has the possibility
to become a new virus
that circulates regularly.
- [Narrator] So how does monkeypox spread
and what can be done to
contain this outbreak?
It's called monkeypox
because it was first
detected in research monkeys
and because it's closely
related to smallpox.
- The way I think about smallpox,
it's the human version of monkeypox.
It's not engineered to exploit
human cells and human bodies.
We're like an accidental host.
- [Narrator] Monkeypox is
endemic to parts of Africa
where it mostly circulates among rodents.
Occasionally, from close interactions,
like hunting or eating,
monkeypox will spread
from an animal to a human,
and in May of 2022,
someone showing symptoms
traveled from Nigeria
to the United Kingdom.
Soon after, other cases
began appearing in the U.K.,
then Portugal, Sweden, the U.S.
- Previously the outbreaks
were fairly limited.
Epidemiologists were able
to bring it under control.
In the current outbreak,
it's spreading fairly
efficiently between humans,
primarily through sexual contact.
- [Narrator] When infected,
monkeypox gets into your bloodstream
and creates lesions on the skin.
While it can spread through
respiratory droplets
or bodily fluids, with this
2022 outbreak, it's rare.
The most common way it spreads
is through skin-to-skin
contact with those lesions.
- We know that during
intimate contact or cuddling,
et cetera, you make these
micro-abrasions in the skin.
You can't really see it a lot
of times, but they're there.
So the virus just jumps
from the person who has it,
and there's tons of it, into
one of these micro-abrasions.
- [Narrator] Once infected,
it can take a while
for symptoms to appear.
That can happen as soon as
five days after infection
to nearly three weeks after,
but they usually appear around here,
and these first few days of symptoms
look like a typical illness
as your immune system kicks in
to begin fighting the disease:
fever, headache, fatigue,
and even the swelling of your lymph nodes.
It's after that, that the rash
and lesions typically begin,
especially on the hands and face.
With the outbreak that began in 2022,
the lesions appeared differently.
They can be localized more on the genitals
and even appear more like bumps,
something that not all
medical professionals
are trained to identify.
- [Kevin] Even when I
went into Urgent Care,
they told me that this was
definitely not monkeypox,
because the way that
monkeypox had been appearing
in photos that they've received,
were larger lesions, umbilicated,
so kind of like donut-shaped,
all throughout the body,
and I just didn't have
any of that at the time.
- People thought to have visible rashes,
like what you'd see in the textbooks,
were these huge boils on people's arms,
but they could be very, very subtle.
- [Narrator] Dr. Chin-Hong
was able to diagnose
and prescribe Kevin TPOXX,
an antiviral medication
that the government
already had stockpiled.
- [Caitlin] There was
a lot of preparedness,
particularly after the
September 11th attacks
and the anthrax mailings,
that went into preparing for smallpox.
We had a lot of tools
already in the arsenal
to fight smallpox but that
also worked for monkeypox.
- [Narrator] The stockpile
includes an approved vaccine.
U.S. authorities are
testing already-made doses
and ordering 2.5 million more.
- And so we are in a
relatively good position
against this virus than we
would be against a virus
that we had never prepared for before,
but we need to make sure
that we use those tools
appropriately and aggressively
in order to bring this
virus under control.
- [Narrator] The vaccine can also be used
as part of the treatment.
If given within four
days after the exposure,
it can prevent the infection
or at least make it less severe.
- You can develop your antibodies,
because it's, like, so slow,
because it's trying to find
a rat and it's a human.
- [Narrator] The vaccines
to come available
have been restricted to the community
monkeypox is affecting most:
men who have sex with men.
- Among the 6,000 cases
currently reported to the
World Health Organization,
98% are in men who have sex with men,
but we also want to be very careful
not to stigmatize the disease
or to give the impression
that it is exclusively and forever limited
to men who have sex with men,
because that's not the case.
- It's a human virus.
It can attack anyone.
- [Narrator] Public health officials
are concerned about the virus spreading
to other vulnerable groups,
like children or even U.S. animals,
which is why the messaging is the same
as the last outbreak we saw:
"Stop the spread and get vaccinated."
(tense staccato music)